bilder wenige stunden alt aus der region
lohans das ist ganz im osten der ukraine
dort wie der massive beschuss bomben
granaten
explosion kämpfe von unverminderter ja
noch größerer heftigkeit inzwischen und
unser bild reporter paul ronzheimer ist
dort in denen hier gefahren im osten des
landes mittlerweile angekommen wir
hatten ihn von seiner reise aus gier von
den ganzen politischen besuchen dort
dann in den osten des landes berichtet
und da steht er jetzt schon guten morgen
paul ich grüße dich wir sehen diese
bilder und du hast uns ganz eigene
dramatische szenen aus dieser region aus
der ost ukraine mitgebracht schilder uns
einmal was du in den vergangenen stunden
dort erlebt was du gesehen hast
ja wir sind aus nie pro weiter richtung
dom bass gefahren das ist die umkämpfte
region hier geht es um alles und gestern
nacht sind wir von diesen einschlägen
aufgewacht dort an dem ort an dem wir
waren plötzlich hochgeschreckt die wände
haben gewackelt und es gab mehrfach
explosionen ungefähr 500 meter hier von
dem ort entfernt an dem wir uns befinden
hat das wissen des anderen das sind
momente ganz kurz einordnen paul weil
wir schwarz sehen aber das ist natürlich
ein kamerabild das ist so gewollt wir
wollen den zuschauern einen eindruck
geben von dem klang der nacht dort wie
du sie erlebt hast
das war deckung
schauspieler uns einfach deine eindrücke
gerne ich wollte nur die zuschauer noch
einmal mitnehmen in dieses sehen
genau dieser klang der nacht diese
explosion das ist etwas dem moment
wo alle wände gewackelt haben hier und
es ist ein ort der immer wieder
beschossen wird wie die gesamte region
wie alles hier angegriffen wird mit
massiver gewalt der russischen armee
sowohl gradwohl artillerie
raketen alles wird hier eingesetzt wenn
wladimir putin will offenbar in dieser
woche noch die region luhansk komplett
erobern das sind diese orte über die
viel gesprochen wo des jahres lizenz
aber auch der donbass wo ich mich
befinde wird massiv attackiert ich war
das letzte mal vor sechs wochen hier und
das ist kein vergleich zu dem was hier
vor sechs wochen
du hast die ganzen krieg die ganze
ukraine im blick welche geschichte
kannst du uns aktuell erzählen über die
situation in diesem land das verheißt
alles mit unserem blick nichts gutes
seit wochen mittlerweile für den bestand
der ukraine oder
es wird immer schwieriger für die
ukraine hier vor allem weil die waffe
nicht ankommen kann das ist zumindest
das was mir ukrainische offiziere
ukrainische generäle sagen dass die
munition ausgeht dass nicht genügend
waffen da sind sie verteidigen sich
immer noch mit zehntausenden an dieser
linie und die russen sind in den
vergangenen wochen immer nur 10 15
kilometer vielleicht weitergekommen aber
sie wollen jetzt dieser einkesselung
zumindest im kleinen und im kleinen
bedeutet dann wären tausende ukrainische
soldaten eingekesselt das würde die
ukraine unbedingt verhindern aber es
sieht momentan nach leichten vorteilen
für russland aus